we're going to start with the historic
victory for women's rights in latin
america
where senators in argentina have voted
to legalize abortion
after a marathon session 38 senators
voted for legalizing terminations
of up to 14 weeks while 29 senators
voted against up to five hundred and
twenty thousand women sought illegal
abortions in argentina each year
forty thousand of them ended up in
hospital after complications
during the procedure theresa beau is
joining us from buenos aires studies in
the last
hour or so we've been seeing jubilant
scenes from the supporters of the bill
but a very dejected scene
from those opposed to it
[Music]
well that's correct it's a very divisive
issue
in this mostly catholic country we're
here uh people have started to leave now
because they've been here for at least
12 hours that's how long the debate in
the senate
uh lasted uh they were celebrating
singing
crying women who have been struggling
for what they say is a right
uh in this country and as you just said
a half a million abortions
are carried out every year that end up
in many cases with complications mostly
affecting women
but with no resources that's why women
who were just a few minutes ago here
were saying that this was a matter
of social justice because women with no
resources
end up in a hospital afraid of going
there because abortion is illegal in the
country and they could be
reported to the police but on the other
side of this plaza where we are right in
front of congress there was
a completely different atmosphere an
atmosphere
a somber add more fear again people
crying because this is the
they were saying that this is the worst
day in argentina's history
uh basically saying that uh abortion
should remain
illegal but women who were here uh
before
were telling us is that abortion it's
already happening in the country and
that in the past
the catholic church uh pope francis who
has been
personally lobbying against this law
they have opposed
the law of divorce in this country same
sex marriage law
and abortion and that it's time to
change and that's why
this law is historic and it's crucial to
save women's lives
teresa i think argentina if i'm right in
thinking this is the first country in
latin america to make a decision like
this
what are the ramifications for the rest
of the
of the countries across latin america
[Applause]
well it has this sets a huge precedent
argentina is not the
first country uruguay tiny uruguay was
the first country in the region to
legalize abortion cuba
is another country where abortion is
legal but argentina is the first
large country in the region where
abortion becomes legal
women in argentina from now on will be
able to go to a hospital
and request an abortion until the 14th
week
of pregnancy so this is important
because in many cases
argentina has been an example in other
issues
like divorce like same-sex marriage and
now abortion we were talking just to
human rights groups and they're saying
that countries like brazil like colombia
like peru
are looking at argentina how this bill
was treated how the women rights groups
who have been on the streets wearing
this green handkerchiefs that
have become known not only in argentina
but throughout latin america
how they have handled this campaign and
they're definitely taking a close look
and they're definitely going to continue
the struggle that legalized abortion
in this country and that many hope will
spread throughout the region
theresa thank you very much indeed
theresa bower talking to us from buenos
aires